hello friends this week on the ketchup
as the summer movie season heats up we
are dropping the information hammer down
with everything we know about the next
thor movie and as we head into pride
month all during the month of june we'll
be looking at some of the most
groundbreaking lgbtq plus characters in
the history of tv and film on our show
rt essentials we're also going to be
checking out the ultimate head to head
to head to head battle on the show
versus with tessa thompson versus aubry
plaza versus sarah paulson versus
janelle monae oh my plus we're gonna sit
down with the cast of dr strange in the
multiverse of madness and through our
rotten tomatoes scene and color film
series we're gonna be checking in on
last year's selected filmmakers all that
and so much more right now on the
ketchup brought to you by target
welcome to the ketchup your destination
for the latest news in the world of
movies and tv straight from rotten
tomatoes and by the way you gotta stick
around because we've also got streaming
recommendations from yours truly because
i watch like a lot of stuff and maybe i
can help steer you toward your next
great binge
these hands were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
phase four of the mcu will be bringing
the thunder and spreading a little love
this summer with the july arrival of the
fourth film in the thor franchise but
there's a lot that we need to hammer i'm
sorry figure out before its release i
already used a hammer pun so let's take
a look at everything we know about thor
love and thunder right now on the
ketchup this film will pick up after the
events of thor ragnarok and avengers end
game with thor still trying to find his
way from not so fit thor to a more
recognizable version of himself while
also bumming around with the guardians
of the galaxy crew
and while we gotta believe that he will
break away during the film and let them
do a third volume of their own thing
considering guardians of the galaxy vol
3 is due in may of 2023 the first
trailer is heavy on star-lord and
friends who perhaps help thor in dealing
with some of his issues i mean i need
their help with making a good road trip
playlist because those guardians always
have the best soundtrack look into the
eyes of the people that you love
[Music]
and one of those issues is the shocking
reality of a new thor as in someone else
worthy of holding mjolnir and harnessing
its power as we first officially heard
three years ago at comic-con the mantle
will now go to natalie portman's jane
foster character an idea first seen in
jason aaron's the mighty thor comics
and that story also includes jane being
cancer stricken a plotline that portman
has hinted at for this film
but given the presence of the multiverse
in recent phase four installments plenty
of online theories have popped up that
her debut is sore could have a
multiversal element which honestly
wouldn't be too surprising
and along with jane foster and the
guardians we know that tessa thompson's
valkyrie will also appear in this film
last left by thor to rule new asgard now
interviews and discussions since endgame
have hinted that at least part of her
story could include the search for a
queen to share the throne with director
and co-writer taika watiti is also
returning as everyone's favorite rock
creature korg and jamie alexander is
back as lady sith
plus we know that matt damon sam neil
and luke hemsworth are gonna be back as
asgardian actors who played loki odin
and thor in loki's bizarre play from
ragnarok but hey in the world of the
multiverse perhaps they could be a real
thing from another universe who shows up
to save the day i mean yes please
i will tell father what you did here
today
he didn't do it for him
i didn't do it
for him
[Music]
[Applause]
one name we're not so sure about seeing
in this movie is tom hiddleston's low
key despite what he's been through and
the events of the series low-key on
disney plus you gotta think that he'll
make some sort of appearance right i
mean i'll take alligator loki at the
very least he's my favorite variant what
did you expect
as far as new faces go christian bale is
making the move from dc hero to marvel
villain as gore the god butcher who as
the name suggests is probably going to
be a big problem for the asgardians and
others and by others we mean potentially
the greek god zeus being played by
russell crowe in what is said to be a
cameo appearance we also know that
actress akasya sabe is listed as playing
bath set god suggesting that perhaps the
egyptian gods that are troubling oscar
isaac's moon night on the disney plus
series of the same name could play a
role in this film and joining matt damon
and friends as an actor playing hella
will be
melissa mccarthy um yeah i kind of just
realized that i buried the lead on that
one and i am sorry i think you're ready
now to hear a little story about a girl
girl named megan
a girl named megan that didn't have a
very good time in high school
i'm referring to myself when i say megan
it's me megan
i know you look at me now and think boy
she must have breezed through high
school not the case annie
no this was not easy going up and down
the halls picking up with some of the
ideas from thor ragnarok is something
that what tt has promised which will be
interesting to see now with asgard
destroyed and thor formally renouncing
his throne but especially after all of
the visuals from the first trailer it is
clear that thor is definitely going on a
journey in love and thunder and with
tyka surrounding himself with talent
behind the scenes from projects like the
mandalorian doctor strange and venom
plus calling this quote the craziest
film i've ever done i mean it seems like
this is gonna be quite the ride
i need to figure out
exactly who i am
so my friends that is what i can tell
you right now of course you can find
more about this and other marvel films
at ron tomatoes.com and speaking of new
marvel films on the way is a look at our
chat with the cast of the new doctor
strange movie that and so much more
coming up on the ketchup we're going to
take a look at the scene and color film
series presented by target and we're
going to get an update on what last
year's filmmakers are currently up to
check it out
being selected for senior color has made
me really believe in myself this program
really helped me challenge myself and
push myself this really has given me an
opportunity to expand my world it's
great to know that there's a group of
people who are supporting young
filmmakers and actually willing to make
a change in the industry
programs like this can break down
barriers because there's a kid out there
that wants to create films but they may
not see people that look like them when
you can't see yourself then it's just
really hard to know where you're going
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean how cool is that and now we're
gonna do it again so don't forget to
check back in at tomatoes.com this june
to meet this year's filmmakers brought
to you by target okay amigos it is that
time because there's always so much to
see and discuss in the world of movies
and tv we are here to cover all the
bases so let's take a look at the great
moments from some of our other shows in
this week's rt highlights starting with
rt essentials where as part of our
celebration of pride month in the month
of june we took a deep dive into some of
the most groundbreaking lgbtq plus
characters from tv and movies it's
definitely worth the watch and the good
news is is i'm here to bring you a sneak
peek right now enjoy why'd you call me
i told you man
do can't yeah yeah
the next character on this list has such
a story that it took three different
actors to play him i'm talking about
charon from the oscar-winning film
moonlight this coming-of-age drama was
written and directed by barry jenkins
and covers three stages in the life of
the main character chiron childhood
adolescence and early adult life with
three actors alex hibbett ashton sanders
and travonti rhodes telling the story
the film explores the challenges chiron
faces with his sexuality and identity
including the emotional and physical
abuse he endured growing up this marked
the first lgbtq film and the first film
with an all-black cast to win the
academy award for best picture
man
there'll be four other knuckleheads
sitting right next to you
you don't even know
listen
and many have highlighted the importance
of its message not just acceptance of
homosexuality within black communities
but also embracing boys who exist
outside of that hardened world and how
masculinity can be expressed in many
different ways
along with best picture moonlight won
oscars for best adapted screenplay and
best supporting actor for mahershala ali
out of eight nominations total and the
film also won a glad award for
outstanding film and its representation
of lgbtq characters among many many
other awards
and after giving distinct and memorable
performances as chiron alex hibbett went
on to star in the showtime series the
shy ashton sanders appeared in the
critically acclaimed film judas and the
black messiah and trevante rhodes an
accomplished track and field sprinter in
his younger days appeared in the popular
netflix film bird box and moonlight the
second lowest grossing film behind the
hurt locker to win a best picture oscar
continues to be cited as one of the best
films of the 21st century i hope you
enjoyed that sneak peek and for the rest
of that list and plenty of deep dives
into all kinds of topics be sure to
check out more rt essentials
moving on to the rt show that pits
popular stars characters filmmakers and
more against each other in the ultimate
battle for supremacy versus and wait
till you get a load of this episode with
tessa thompson versus aubry plaza versus
sarah paulson versus janelle monae i
have to take a breath but you heard that
right this is versus
round one box office ah the movies we
show up grab our snacks i'm a popcorn
and diet soda man and when the lights go
down we're dazzled delighted and swept
up in a world of pure imagination
especially when said film features
janelle monae sarah paulson aubry plaza
or tessa thompson it's thompson who's
the odds-on favorite in this round
because of that little cinematic
universe from those comic picture books
in fact tessa is the only one of our
four competitors that can boast about
having a billion dollar grocer on the
resume well avengers end game was a
billion dollar engine until it became a
two billion dollar muscle car settling
in at just shy of 2.8 billion dollars
worldwide that kids is what you call a
head start
that's funny but it's not just the mcu
that gives tessa a boost she also has
men in black international and creed 2
both of which hauled in over 200 million
bucks each around the globe the first
creed raked in 173 million dollars and
even the lower budget independent films
like sorry to bother you and selma
turned a nice profit all told thompson's
career total box office is an
astonishing
4.46 billion dollars worldwide with a
perfect average of 446 million sure
avengers and thor ragnarok's 850 million
dollars do the heavy lifting but
valkyrie kicks a ton of ass in those
movies and i'd pay to see more aubry
plaza is also part of a giant movie
machine you ever hear a pixar those
movies make scrooge mcduck numbers and
her turn in monsters university sets the
high bar for her multiplex receipts to
the tune of 743 million little kid
screams i mean uh dollars yeah dollars
that's good enough to propel her career
earnings to over a billion bucks
bolstered by solid comedy profits from
funny people at 71 million dollars mike
and dave need wedding dates at 75
million and her only other film that
took in over 100 million dollars you
guessed it dirty grandpa with 105
million hey whatever it takes to get an
88 million dollar per film average am i
right i like funny people that is my
answer to whatever question you're
asking
i mean that is tough i love all of them
i can't get enough of that show and for
more head-to-head battles with all your
movie and tv favorites be sure to check
out more episodes of versus all right
let's keep this ketchup party going with
a visit to a very strange land and i am
talking about doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness we actually had a
chance to sit down with the cast to try
and figure out just what the heck is
going on with i don't know i mean all of
it and the combos that we had were
anything but maddening take a look
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
so first of all strange is he likes to
fix things he's a perfectionist yeah
he might have made some mistakes along
the way or was there no other way does
he going into this film have regrets do
you think about some of the decisions
he's made where do you want me to start
[Laughter]
i would say
no regrets no i think he's a character
who's learning despite his arrogance and
his willfulness and ego i think he does
he he can bend he can adapt and that's
one of the joys of playing him you you
get to have some pathos and some
you know moments where he's properly
schooled and taught that what he's done
isn't necessarily the right or best
thing to have done
and this is another step in that
evolution you know i think in spider-man
no way home we saw a man who we've got
to know is
someone who's transferred deferred his
ego and his skills from being a
um
a neurosurgeon to being a sorcerer who
while not being a supreme sorcerer in
this version is someone who's omnipotent
and omniscient and just omni everything
um
and that's kind of held in check a
little bit in that film he all the
mistakes he makes so are very human and
relatable i feel like he is someone who
cares for a fellow foot soldier in the
first instance with pizza then sees him
as a kid who's lost his guardian and his
way in his own life
and wants to give him something
that can help him get back and does it
in a very cavalier showing-off way and
then it gets interrupted and everything
that happens in that film happens
and then he becomes a sort of bad parent
you know chasing him around the city
asking for the toy back and
yeah really hits the fan so
but it's human that's a great synopsis
he cares it hits the fan yeah
that should be the tagline um yeah
basically he he cares he does care and
he cares for for people outside of his
own existence and um
we all make mistakes from that when that
happens
sam's talked about and it's been
confirmed i'm not trying to get spoilers
but that you play at least a version at
least one version of strange in this
film whether it's a dream whatever it is
for you as an actor do you approach that
character as a totally new character or
do you springboard off what you've
existed what's existed look i think if
it's if it's still me playing strange
however different the circumstances um
it's important to understand that
there's some kind of origin point that's
the same
um so that's why it's me as the same
actor that's why um i think it feeds
into our understanding of our strange
you see these other characters in
whatever moments you see them having
made choices that result in different
outcomes and
i think that's what the multiverse is a
storyline is great at reflecting of our
own lives the sort of multiple cells we
contain the different roles we are
always playing
in our lives and how our choices affect
the outcomes of our lives was there one
particular aspect of
either
going deeper into the strange character
we know or something that you got to
play that was fresh that was
particularly exciting that you can talk
about all of it i would say because you
know
it's great to have my own outing
although it's a very crowded marquee
there's a lot of story and a lot of
characters in this
it's not all about strangers your name
is on the title yeah yeah
um
but i think it's it's
what am i saying yeah no you learn a lot
about him through what he goes through
but also seeing these other versions of
him and i think
that evolution is important it keeps it
keeps people engaged with him and that's
what's rich about him as a character
yeah he's snarky and arrogant and we
kind of vicariously enjoy that sometimes
but you know he's also not down to size
and he's also taught he also is evolving
this is a kind of a two-parter but how
long would you want to play you've sort
of talked about how this is the tip of
the iceberg it's only scratching the
surface because the multiverse is
blowing up
how long would you want to play this
character for in other iterations i
don't really want to put a time on it
but i'm having i don't feel like i'm in
the middle or the beginning i just don't
know i'm having a really good time i'm
having a really good time being your
doctor strange and i enjoy it and
i left this film going oh yeah i can't
wait for fans to see what he's got to
here but i'm i'm even more excited as to
where he goes next so
you know i'm i'm still um i'm still
going for it if you guys are would a
series be interesting do you think it
would be
i don't know i don't know i don't know i
mean you know it's nice to have the kind
of work i do outside of this and i think
a series obviously as a time commitment
is almost as big as a movie um and when
it's your series you'll as lizzy will
tell you on all the time um
so i don't know i don't know uh sam
yeah i know you were a fan of the
original spider-man films what aspect of
those films did you love
and what sort of nuggets that are very
spider-men asked did you sitting across
from him i know you've done a funny
impression of him as a director sort of
like what sort of freshness does he
bring to this to this story
i mean
fans of his of old will love this
there's a lot of nostalgic sam raimi
touches in his delivery of moments of
horror the kind of schlock horror
element of it
the the the fun he has with
gore in inverted commas who knows what
that means in the multiverse uh you'll
find out um and also jump scares and all
the other traits of horror movie making
and also the darker tone as well and he
handled that as well as the complexes of
the characters and the situations with
real clarity and uh at ease
but the thing i learned most about him
was he's just so amenable he's such a
great collaborator brilliant first
audience he always wants you to try
things and skew the script and come up
with new ideas and
um
and he's so humble i mean to a fool
sometimes he had to kind of remind
himself that he was directing a big
thing
i thought you were going to do an
impression oh god well you said you set
me up for a fool but you know he's like
you know
so in this thing strange it's here and
then this box comes through and you cut
it like a buffalo like
and then it falls into half i feel so
cruel during your personalization it's
not fair in another multiverse story
you're playing him i'm playing him all
right yeah and he plays he plays strange
i'd love to see his strength
i have actually seen history i mean you
know that's the thing he's so animated
and he will give you a whole breakdown
of the scene and he just can't help but
sort of do it and play it out all the
parts he runs from one place
back to the other you know
um
but he's he's a dear man i'm very very
fond of him and and i think he's handled
everything that's been thrown at him
coming into this franchise late this
particular moment of it and in the mcu
um so brilliantly and
uh it's it's very much a sam raimi film
i love it thank you thank you so much
for your time thank you you're welcome
it was fun ah what a great cast and of
course check back here for more
interviews with the stars and creators
of all your favorite movies and shows i
mean what can i say we have access when
it comes to what i've been really into
lately i have to start with winning time
the rise of the lakers dynasty on hbo
max the show follows the lives of the
1980s lakers and takes a look at a team
that literally defined the 80s both on
and off the court this show is such an
adam mckay special so if you're a fan of
adam style like me you are going to love
it it has a mix of genre bending
elements and the pacing is fantastic and
also john c reilly as jerry buss is just
really hard to look away from also fun
fact they had such a hard time finding
an actor who could play magic johnson so
much so that they almost didn't make the
show but get this it has already been
renewed for season two you must watch
this it's a slam dunk another show that
has been appointment viewing watching
for me is the kardashians now on hulu i
mean i will never not be keeping up with
the kardashians we've been following
their lives since 2007 and there is
never a dull moment which is so
impressive in itself because if you
tuned in to what i did in a day i mean
you would change the channel in two
seconds this season we get to see how
kim kardashian and pete davidson met
courtney got engaged to travis barker
and kylie is pregnant again and also the
opening shot of the first episode is
pretty stylized and will suck you in
within seconds and while you're on hulu
if you haven't seen the dropout yet i
highly recommend i mean i would tune in
for amanda seifert's performance alone
so it's the story of former theron ceo
elizabeth holmes who was convicted of
criminal fraud and elizabeth would
actually lower her voice to be taken
more seriously and amanda does an
uncanny job portraying her it has got
emmy nomination written all over it for
sci fred highly highly recommend
well my friends that was fun thanks for
checking out this latest episode of the
ketchup i hope you enjoyed it as much as
i did be sure to stay tuned to the ryan
tomatoes channel for more of your
favorite movies and tv and for scores
recommendations and more be sure to
check out rottentomatoes.com i am nas
perez and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]